he is baseball hall-of-famer getting set
to play with Trent Dilfer and Mark rip
and he is Tom Glavine here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Tom
I'm good rich how you doing I am doing
just fine how's the golf game how is it
uh you know it's typical moments of
brilliance and moments of not such great
brilliant so we'll see we'll see what
shows up this weekend okay so are you
aware of what your odds are to win it
are you aware of this and not know it's
funny somebody mentioned those odds to
me yesterday but I don't know what my
odds are okay I am going to break news
to Tom Glavine here you are fifty to one
to win this tournament you are amongst
your pitching brethren at fifty to one
Roger Clemens Josh Beckett David Wells
and Greg Maddux 50 to one your thoughts
Tom Glavine ah
that's handy Paul right I mean a lot of
things would have to go right for me to
win I mean there's some guys out here
they can play some guys that hit the
ball a long long way so I mean that
certainly is advantageous for them so I
think for me it's going to be keep it in
play and make some putts and see what
happens so you never know can you beat
Maddux head up straight up what do you
think I can yes I can whether or not I
do um
I guess we'll find out sounds like
somebody who has done that time I have
done that I've beat him a few times he's
got me a few times I've gotten smoked
see you know a little bit but uh you
know so so we'll see how the tournaments
are always a different animal you know
you got a so much of it is managing your
emotions and your expectations so you
never you never know how that else is
going to play off Smoltz is 8 to 1 Tom
Glavine uh with the general hospital'
dreamboat from back in the day Jack
Wagner at 8 to 1 and then your two
playing partners Trent Dilfer is 10 to 1
and Mark rippin 701 so you're you're
going to be in this mixer Tom well I got
to tell you actually I'm playing with
Smoltz in Maddox today so you are yeah
Trenton those guys are the group behind
me ah but that that's about right i mean
you know jack can play he was uh you
know he was in contention last year and
you know certainly smokes you has the
ability to to make a bunch of birdies
and you know I know Trent Dilfer has got
a good game so um you know and Mark
Griffin's own you know marks marks one
of those guys that doesn't hit it a ton
but he teaches
lay and scores pretty well so I would
say all those guys have somewhat of a
chance alright so your breaking news to
me you're playing with Smoltz and Maddux
today why not I mean we're brilliant
paring right there with all the big
three here on the Rich Eisen show with
Tom Glavine right now okay so as for the
here and now in Major League Baseball if
you picked up a baseball could you tell
if it was juiced do you think um you
know at this particular moment I don't
know but I think you know we went
through a similar thing you know when we
were all playing and in their mid to
early 90s where there were some some
talk of the balls being juiced a little
bit and I think there was something to
it you know there was you know there was
definitely a difference in the baseball
is that one particular year and and it's
it's more it's more in what you noticed
in terms of being able to to manipulate
the baseball so to speak you know every
pitcher gets a ball whether it's a new
ball or rub by the umpires and we still
have to fiddle with it we still have to
rubber we still have to you know put our
own touch on it and there were some
times in those in that year where we
were going through it that that leather
was wound a little bit tighter it was a
little bit harder to you know you take
your fingernail and stick it into the
leather baseball it's going to put a
little bit of an indentation in it and
then there was a year where it was
really hard to do that so if my guess is
if if pitchers are talking about it and
they think there's something different
about the baseball than my guess is
there probably is something to it so
what was it about the baseball other
than that you couldn't just stick a
fingernail into it and make some form of
an indentation back in that that year
Tom well when they're when they're that
way they just feel really like they're
wound really tightly it's almost like
you have a you've got a golf ball in
your hand you know and when that when it
happens you know the seams are not quite
as prevalent on the ball as you're used
to so you know that affects obviously
breaking balls it affects movement on
all your other pitches so if there was a
like I say definitely year were
sometimes you'd get a baseball that the
umpire would throw to you and be like
you know there's there's no way I'm
using this you throw back and try and
find another one was that the famed
chicks dig the long ball here time I was
in that yeah I was in that era so maybe
that had something to do it so maybe I'm
partly to blame
knocked on your door to say would you
like to be in a commercial with Heather
Locklear we did ice pack in the day you
know I was it was funny my agent
actually asked me earlier in that year
if I wanted to do something with Nike
and I said sure why not I had no idea
what it was and then you know they they
tell you the concept and what they're
trying to do and you know even when
you're going through it it's kind of
it's kind of goofy because it's pieced
together and we did it over a couple of
days on a road trip half of it was in
Florida half it was in Philadelphia and
even as you're doing it you're like what
are we doing what are they doing with
this you know what it all came together
it was pretty funny and I credit myself
with um you know resurrecting Heather
Locklear's career you and Melrose Place
Tom was an unbeatable combination for
her I think when it all came just in
retrospect in retrospectively
Tom Glavine hall-of-famer joining me
here before he tees off with the other
big three Greg Maddux and John Smoltz in
the first round of the American Century
championship here on the Rich Eisen show
so how would a pitching clock have
affected you Tom um probably not much I
mean you know we were all of the mindset
that get the ball and go you know and
and you know obviously it's a little bit
different when you have runners on base
you know that that's the proverbial you
got to slow the game down a little bit
which you know I think a lot of younger
players younger pitchers have trouble
with the game you know guys start
getting on base to start getting in
trouble the game goes fast and your
brains going a million miles an hour and
it's got ability to slow things down
when you're getting into some trouble
that I think helps an awful lot and the
ability to do that is certainly a big
asset for guys that can do it but you
know with nobody on base um it wouldn't
have been an issue because I think we
were all of the mindset give me the ball
and let's make my pitch and and you know
after the pitch is over get them all
back and try to make your next one you
know you want to keep your your guys
behind you as engaged in the game as you
can and keep them as ready as you can
and if you're taking you know a minute
in between pitches
that's the best way to get your
infielders and outfielders on their
heels and and you know kind of lose
their attention a little bit of your 22
years in Major League Baseball 22 season
17 you had 30 and more starts you've led
the league and games started six times
our players and pitchers being babied
today Tom
don't see these numbers anymore no yeah
I think they are is it's no fault of
their own you know I mean look I I think
I went through or we went through a
similar similar argument in my
generation what's the five-man rotation
and guys you know not pitching 300
innings a year I think it's all it's all
in how you're brought up and these guys
today are being brought up that you know
five or six innings max is all you need
out of a starting pitcher and and you
know when you have some of these
bullpens that are constructed the way
that they are where you've got guy after
guy coming out of the bullpen that's
throwing 95 to 100 miles an hour it's
hard for a manager to leave a starting
pitcher in there to flip a lineup for
the third or fourth time when he can go
to those toys that he has out there in
the bullpen so you know a lot of it is
it's just simply how the game is played
now but I do I do think that by and
large guys are being babied a little bit
too much in today's game a couple more
minutes left with Tom Glavine baseball
hall-of-famer when was the last time you
smoked and Maddox hung out together how
often does it sound you know it's been
it's been better lately you know with
with the Hall of Fame inductions and
certainly this event here in Tahoe and
another one that we do in January with
Diamond Resorts you know we get together
two or three times a year at least now
which is great I mean there was a
stretch there were you know when we were
all retired and kind of doing our thing
I didn't see these guys for a while so I
think two years ago when we played in
this event together that was the first
time that three of us had played around
the golf since we got done playing so
it's nice now like I say with these with
these events a couple times a year to
kind of bring us all together so it's
fun what's the best safe for work Greg
Maddux prank you can tell me Tom oh my
god you know everybody always asks about
Greg and I think he has a reputation for
being a little bit um I guess disgusting
would be a good word um so there's a lot
of things you can't you just can't tell
about Greg but you know he's he's not
one to shy away from doing something
disgusting or trying to do something to
embarrass somebody so when you're around
him you got to be on your toes so you
don't have one specific one that you
could don't
long it's just now I don't what's the
angriest you've ever seen Bobby Cox Tom
oh that would probably be there'd be a
couple of those um you know I watched on
one time coming after a game that we
lost due to a miscommunication on a
pop-up and and flip the the spread the
table over that had all the host games
food on it so you know dealers to say
everybody was starting to go to dinner
active game mice I watched him change
Andrew Jones his career when he pulled
them off the field in the middle of the
game and then proceeded the air mount in
the dugout down in the tunnel so I've
seen Bobby on a few occasions where he's
he's led into some guys but it's usually
warranted and message is usually
delivered and it doesn't happen yeah for
those who might not know how did he
change Andrew Jones his career couple
minutes and well you know Andrew was
such a good outfielder obviously that it
was more of a surprise when he didn't
catch the ball so there was a play or a
ball that was you know kind of softly
hit and Andrew didn't get a great jump
on it and looked like he kind of didn't
go after it and Bobby was less than
thrilled with his effort on the place so
to speak and in the middle of the inning
he pulled him off the field brought him
down into the into the tunnel of the
dugout and proceeded to pretty much air
mode and you know tell him I don't know
who you think you are but we're not
going to do that anymore and I think
part of it was to send a message to
Andrew but I think part of it was you
know just to get Andrew to understand
how good he was and what he was capable
of doing and to make sure he did it
every night and from that point on you
know Andrew was what he was and arguably
one of the greatest center fielders ever
played kick ok last one out of you
Maddux and Smoltz which one of you would
have the best chance of beating the
fries Tom in Atlanta who man I'm going
to say I'm gonna say Smoltz II he you
know he's got these big he's got those
long legs so long strides
if I was on skates I could beat them but
I don't think I can be in there spray ok
by the way I lied last question are you
part of are you part of though are you
still in the mix to maybe by the Marlins
one of the groups Tom I am worse we're
still in the mix we're in a good
position so now it's just kinda were
we're waiting to see what happens
hopefully something's going to come to a
conclusion here relatively soon but yeah
we're still in it and I feel good about
our group in our position so we'll see
what happens and you be want to be part
of the front office should that happen
yes absolutely I think it'd be be
something that it would be fun to be a
part of and you know have the
opportunity to be a part of the you know
an organization and shaping an
organization and and you know how how
they're going about their business is
something that I'm certainly interested
in doing so I hope happens Tom
appreciate you calling in before heading
to the first tee good luck go ahead and
take them down take them down to talking
to you you got it it's Tom Glavine the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy